Did you know that cells in your body can recycle pieces of themselves?
It's an incredible process that we're learning more about...
...thanks to the work of one Japanese scientist.
Yoshinori Ohsumi was awarded the Nobel Prize in physiology or medicine...
...on October 3rd for his work in understanding how cells recycle...
...their own damaged or worn-out content.
The process is called autophagy,...
...a term that means "self-eating" and it's a real lifesaver.
Cells will break down proteins and use them for energy if a person is starving.
The process also allows cells to destroy viruses and bad bacteria.
Ohsumi has been studying autophagy for decades using baker's yeast.
His work has helped shed light on how problems with autophagy...
...can contribute to diseases like cancer and Parkinson's.
David Rubinsztein with the Institute for Medical Research...
...at the University of Cambridge told The Associated Press...
...Ohsumi's work quote "opened the door to a field."
For NewsBeat Social, I'm Cambrie Caldwell.